what's going on guys this is Rob and in
order to keep from driving myself insane
by making the same kind of video every
single day I'm going to try something
new and I have no clue what direction
this is going to take but what I do want
to talk about right now is how Deadpool
was a member of the x-men a little bit
of backstory here so there was this
group called the Illuminati and the
Illuminati were like Charles Xavier and
dr. strange and iron man and like Reed
Richards and their goal was to basically
keep the planet protected they were like
we're going to operate behind the scenes
and we're going to keep the earth
protected and we're going to make sure
that nobody attacks it and one of the
first things they did is they went off
world to a planet that belong to a race
called the scrolls and the scrolls could
basically shape-shift keep that the back
of your mind because that's going to be
important but the scrolls could
shape-shift and the Illuminati were like
hey look scrolls you guys have been
messing with our race for a while you've
been showing up on earth when we don't
want you to all your little Wars all the
kind of stuff keep that to yourselves
don't show up on our planet and the
scrolls are like you know what you're
coming with us
so they kidnapped the Illuminati they
basically start experimenting on them
they analyze the bodies and then they
send them back to earth with no idea of
what happened so fast forward
there's Marvel Civil War and I've got a
five hour series on if we haven't seen
Civil Wars two gravely Q's longer than
but basically it was Captain America on
the side of freedom Iron Man on the side
of security and they were split by the
superhuman Registration Act and they
basically waste war against one another
for a while and an Iron Man's team won
done and done Iron Man becomes a
director of shield and he's basically in
charge of the United States national
security we'll come to find out
throughout the entire event of Civil War
the scrolls had secretly been replacing
people and superheroes with squirrel
replicants that took place in an event
called Secret Invasion and so once a
secret invasion event comes to an end
and once the world figures out what was
going on they get rid of Tony Stark well
during Secret Invasion Norman Osborn the
Green Goblin the villain of Spider Man
had literally shot and killed the scroll
Queen and so the world was like oh my
god Norman Osborn is amazing he
literally saved humanity and so for
reasons that I don't understand they
make a Norman Osborn the director of
shield well Norman Osborn being a bad
guy is like you know we're going to do
we're going to do bad guy stuff and so
he basically starts implementing these
little dictatorial plans and trying to
make himself absolute ruler of the
United States and so on
the x-men are like nope we're not having
any part of that and so they leave the
continental United States and they move
to an island off the coast of San
Francisco and the reason why is because
if they're not part of the continental
United States Norman Osborn cannot
directly affect them he has to use these
crappy means well during this time this
guy named Ellis Kincaid is just making
these absolutely ridiculous claims he's
like the x-men are evil and the x-men
are bad and they're bad because they
moved off the coast of San Francisco and
they took my daughter with them because
she's an x-man and I can't see her I'm
not allowed to talk to her so on and so
forth and the x-men are like oh my god
this is a major issue well at the same
time that all this is happening Deadpool
is like I'm tired of being a hero for
hire I'm tired of doing contracts I want
to have something like meaningful I want
to do something meaningful with my life
and so Deadpool is watching this
broadcast by psychos whether like we're
the x-men and you guys didn't want us in
the United States anymore and we're
tired everything is going on so we're
literally just leaving and Deadpool is
like man like Cyclops wants me to be an
x-man does it make any sense nope but
it's Deadpool don't ask questions so
Deadpool goes to Cyclops and he's like
hey man can I be an x-men and Cyclops is
like absolutely not no way you're going
to be an x-man and Deadpool was like oh
okay and so he's sad and then he walks
away cue the sad music from The
Incredible Hulk and so what is up
happening is Wolverine is like looks
like laughs we've been friends for a
long time even though I've always want
to get with Jean Grey but I couldn't
because you were with her whatever
that's old news cuz Jean Grey's long
since been dead he's like you messed up
and Cyclops is like how and he was like
sometimes it's better to keep your
enemies close and your friends closer
something on those lines I don't know
have somebody keep an eye on Deadpool
and Cyclops is like okay not a bad idea
so they go to Domino and they're like
hey Domino he used to bang cable back in
the day right and she's like yeah and
they're like you were friends with
Deadpool back in the day right and she's
like well not really friends but I knew
him and they're like okay you need to go
keep an eye on Deadpool and she's like
why me and they were like because all
the stuff we just said and so she's like
okay fine so she goes to see Deadpool
and Deadpool's like camping out because
he as soon as he's an x-man now even
though he was told that he wasn't and
he's looking at the Scott Ellis Kincaid
most likely he's going to assassinate
him not really sure but he hears Domino
coming and he turns around and he was
like you came here to kill me and she's
like no I didn't and he was like yeah
Cyclops sent you here to kill me she's
like no way I just came here to tell you
that you can be part of the x-men and
he's like take some steps back and she's
like okay and he's like take some more
steps back she's like okay and then he
shoots a glass out from under her come
to find out earlier in the day
Deadpool he made like three hundred and
seventy two thousand pancakes and she
landed on them and so while she's
covered in pancakes to her in Deadpool
or eating the pancakes and so he's like
I could to be an x-man and she's like
yep and he's like absolutely awesome
that's so cool but he's like only under
one condition she's like what's that and
he was like I want to wear my own
uniform and so like while Domino's
telling Cyclops all this stuff Cyclops
is like we don't have an x-man suit and
she was like no Deadpool made his own
x-man suit it's yellow and black and it
looks amazing because it says Deadpool
on the back and so Cyclops is like okay
whatever and so Deadpool becomes one of
the x-men well the first thing he does
is create an absolute public relations
nightmare by literally trying to stage
an assassination on Ellis Kincaid on
live TV
Wally's in the middle of an interview
and Cyclops is like oh my god we got to
do something about this and so they show
up and they're like Deadpool you got to
stop this and Deadpool is like no way
I'm an x-man this is what we do in
Cyclops is like we do not assassinate
people we're not assassins that's not
what we do we help people and we try to
stave off humanity hating us but we also
give like unis a home and that feels
like man that sucks
and so he was like I'm not going to
surrender that's when you guys are
expecting no way that's going to happen
and so Deadpool ends up getting in a
battle with like Colossus like he spits
blood in his face and he ends up getting
into a battle of Cyclops and he's
battling all the x-men and all hell's
breaking loose and his absolute
pandemonium and then eventually Deadpool
gets the upper hand on Cyclops so he
puts a gun to his head
well then Cyclops turns around looks at
Deadpool shoots him as optic beams well
it turns out there's this guy who's been
recording the entire event and his
cameras running low on battery power
well then Anna's camera eventually dies
the entire conflict stops her cyclases
like what the hell's going on here well
it turns out that Norman Osborn had
nothing to do with any of this
instead Deadpool could basically set it
all up he reasoned with the fact that
the x-men were viewed as criminals in
the eyes of the world and the only way
for them to rectify that fact was to be
viewed as heroes and so Deadpool made
himself one of the x-men
then when I'll try to commit an
assassination and then film the entire
thing on national television so that
people could see that the x-men were
actually saving humanity and they were
getting rid of rogue villainous mutants
and so in the end yet remember good guys
Deadpool save the day yet again and then
he was no longer an x-man anymore that's
it with that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you guys later peace